That was a tricky question, and you couldn't really know the answer
if you've never seen probability before,
but the answer is 0.25.
And I will derive it for you using something called a truth table.
In a truth table, you draw out every possible outcome
of the experiment that you conducted.
There were two coin flips--flip 1 and flip 2--and each had
a possible outcome of heads, heads; heads, tails; tail, heads; and tail, tail.
So when we look at this table, you can see every possible outcome of these two coin flips.
There happens to be four of them.
And I would argue because heads and tails are equally likely,
each of these outcomes is equally likely.
Because we know that the probability of all outcomes has to add up to 1,
we find that each outcome has a chance of a quarter, or, 0.25.
Another way to look at this is the probability of heads followed by heads
is the product .
What are the chances of the first outcome to be heads
multiplied by the probability of the second outcome to be heads?
The first is 0.5, as is the second.
And if you multiply these two numbers, it's 0.25, or, a quarter.